you
everyone is Jerry I'm on chest coms
tactics train I'm going to do another
group of three puzzles and share my
thoughts along the way here so wait to
play in this first one okay for starters
we're down a minor piece we do have a
very dangerous pawn however on a six how
dangerous exactly well hmm we're in a
unique position where when this pawn
pushes there's two different ways it has
the potential to promote pawn takes
knight or a 8 equals Queen hmm so this
might factor in and yeah I think it does
yeah I think it definitely is factoring
in I think the first move is one that's
going to address the unprotected nature
of the black position there's a rook on
e8 unprotected a knight in a queen queen
to be five hits all three and if Queen
takes Queen Bishop takes the rook is hit
and a7 is a very serious threat I
believe that this is it and I think I
have to consider anything else yes that
is correct
Bishop takes and now this is just a very
deadly trap that's the end of the puzzle
this pawn push is just a huge huge
threat with a knight if the pawn if PAH
never pushes - well from White's
perspective if it pushes to the seventh
rank and is attacking a knight there's
even some situations where black could
be up a knight and a rook and there's
not a way to prevent the pawn from a
queening just because of these multiple
ways of promoting and it's a on its way
to that eighth rank so yeah if the rook
moves here a seven is just going to win
in this case okay that one wasn't too
bad just recognizing the unprotected
pieces and tying in this idea of
haven't been quite strong let's try
puzzle two of three hmm okay well my eye
is immediately going towards this move
here since it is discovered check well
since it'll be double check I should be
saying pawn takes pawn both queen pawn
hitting the king I really do want to
look into the checking moves for sure on
this one because I don't want to have to
calculate these Queen checks not that
there would be so many yeah not that
there would be so many on Queen b1 King
here on Queen a1 there's King here so if
the Queen goes to a dark we would go to
a light if the Queen goes to a light we
would go to a dark just to sidestep and
ensuing diagonal check but let's not
even focus on this Queen just yet
candidate moves to start okay there's a
couple of night checks there's also this
pawn takes one of these three let's see
what would be the great follow up if
Knight here I really see it ninety-seven
King here now what I don't see it I
don't see a great follow up what about
Knight h6 check Knight h6 check HM hm
all right let's let's consider this
double check first pawn takes pawn king
takes and that's for strike pawn takes
pawn
if King goes here here then Queen h6
game over
so pawn takes pawn King takes now what
hmm King takes there is Queen c7 check
forcing well he has a couple options
from that point maybe we don't have to
play Queen e7 pawn takes pawn King here
oh my goodness it's a meeting to pawn
takes pawn King takes Knight here game
over okay
yeah pawn takes pawn king here knight
here covers both EA and f7 pawn takes
pawn king to one of these two Queen h6
game over this is a main two puzzle that
is correct and that's checkmate okay
last one Oh glad I did not miss that one
took me too long though for that one
it's very forcing it's been too much
time on that Queen move the black Queen
moving okay team black in this third and
final puzzle let's see hmm are we doing
material-wise even okay this cool this
night isn't a pin all right hmm well my
first thought is to actually react to
this threat of Queen takes Knight
hmm and I was saying that because any
Knight move and then we're back on with
this being a threat but second thought
you know I don't know after if we let's
say move Knight f6 Knight f6 there's
captures on here not that it's the best
but I don't see the puzzle I don't see
that as being the solution giving up
them to minor pieces for a rook and pawn
it isn't good for white but that
wouldn't be a solution to a puzzle so we
need to look for something
or what about just pawn takes Knight
pawn takes Knight and I was thinking
pawn takes Knight Queen takes Knight and
then g6 but we have to be careful this
pawn is pinned so pawn takes Knight
Queen takes Knight g6 will be met with
Queen takes pawn so maybe this is still
okay pawn takes Knight Queen takes
Knight and then something else hmm what
are their moves to consider I wonder
what it'd be Knight takes f4 that
doesn't seem like it'd be enough Knight
takes pawn
Bishop takes and then we take here oh
that is actually working because at the
end of it we end up with the fork ah
that is the solution Knight takes f4
looking at the forward moves Knight
takes pawn we're ready to just scoop up
this night and I was missing like when
we capture here that well we're actually
winning some material but we're
following up with a fork which is
winning even more material I believe
this is it let me just double check
Knight takes f4 Bishop takes Knight pawn
takes Knight getting the piece back and
doing so with the fork that's gotta be
it it is correct pawn takes and at the
end of it we're scooping up this piece
here and being up material that is the
solution okay not too bad compared to
the last group of three if you saw that
set for sure that a third puzzle is one
that I still
I still think about it was a quite
involved but not so bad a group of three
puzzles in this one as usual feel free
to share how you did with these three in
the comments section below
and I'll catch you in the next video
take care bye
you